hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
paladins the team based free-to-play
first-person shooter has finally made it
onto ps4 and Xbox one at this point
you'll have one of three reactions one
Oh a new game let's check it out
two free to play you mean pay to bloody
win or three is this a normal watch
ripoff well I'm here to look at those
questions but more importantly here are
nine reason to give colored in to try on
your console let's start off with a
quick overview you are one of five team
members task with claiming and defending
a siege engine standing in close
proximity to the cart allows it to roll
forward with the payload hold the other
team off the long enough and you win
it's that simple if you want it to be it
kind of sounds like another game doesn't
it
each team needs balance to be successful
and to achieve this there are 25 heroes
I mean champions in four typical play
styles to pick from these are frontline
damaged flank and support your front
liners have the most health and their
primary role is to protect the payload
and defend objectives they are usually
bullet sponges with shields and
short-range weaponry the damage dealers
are here to shoot the [ __ ] out of the
enemy forcing them to act defensively
there's a quarter healers of the group
although they can do a bit of fighting
as well too and finally the flankers are
here to skirt around the enemy and shoot
them in the back like a true hero would
let's deal with that elephant in the
room paladins and overwatch are very
similar aren't they the game modes the
characters the art styles are very close
to one another and damn it even the
music in paladin's reminds me of
overwatch but I'm going to stick my neck
out and hope no and chops this off and
say paladin's is more than an overwatch
clone if you're a DC and Marvel fan you
should be familiar with Deathstroke and
Deadpool well DC's Deathstroke first
appeared in 1980 and Marvel's Deadpool
was created in 1991 as a direct ripoff
of Deathstroke even the characters real
names Slade Wilson and Wade Wilson I bet
you're thinking what's your boy Adam
well my point is look at how different
the characters are today Deadpool in
particular carry music that is due to
the added depth the character have and
I'm not saying this will happen with
overwatch and paladin but I am saying
there is more depth currently in paladin
if you're willing to look for it a great
way paladins distances itself from
overwatch is via a card system similar
to those found in a typical mall bar
like Kerrigan or daughter - as you play
the game you'll start unlock chests yes
like overwatch but the items you find
inside and not always cosmetic items
these cards can subtly change the way
you play the game giving you health
boosts or quicker ability cooldowns to
name a few
this allows you to build a unique
character so when you go one-on-one with
the same champion you may be able to
stand and fight long enough to kill your
opponents or proper defensive action and
live to fight another day lilo this is a
gigantic system of variables and nuances
which all the watch hasn't even
considered for its audience that's what
I mean by depth one of the greatest
things about overwatch is the ability to
change characters constantly to ship the
battle in your favor
well power demons does not allow you to
change your characters during the match
what you and your team chooses from the
outset remains there for the full fight
at first this stressed me out no ends as
playing with randoms would result in
massive
on balance king but paladin's does have
a way around this an item purchasing
system to upgrade your characters before
each round or after each death if your
damage dealers aren't pulling their
weight then upgrade your character to
deal additional damage to rebalance your
team take Fernando I would usually use
this chap to defend the payload but some
of the damage dealers in my team were
evicted early so I turned him into a
wrecking ball to try and change the
fight into our favor I'm not saying I'm
very good I'm just saying the nuances
are there to help out different areas of
your team
double to paladin's is constantly
changing receiving updates and adding
champions approximately one champion is
added each month which drastically
changes the battlefield and keeps the
game feeling fresh the influences of
each character is pretty obvious whether
that's because it's a direct copy of a
character's likeness such as a tree
named Grover who I'm sure it's pretty
heavily inspired by groot from guardians
of the galaxy the overwatch rip offs are
here too and good old region specific
stereotypes make an appearance too in
their defense though it has to find the
game which is truly original heck even
overwatch was considered a team fortress
ripoff a long time ago
I even called Hangzhou mitsurugi when I
first started playing over wash your
music remodeler the pay2win question
will always arise if you're getting
something for nothing
it's definitely the right way to think
about things there's even a saying that
goes along with it if it's too good to
be true it probably is
as recent as April there has been
allegations of Penta win in paladins
from the community i looked more
in-depth at this and from what i can
gather a tweak to the essent system
which is one of the games revenue
structures is harder to obtain in the
quantities needed to unlock the high-end
cards is it still possible yeah of
course it is but the levels of grind
needed to achieve that has ramped up the
core mechanics have not been touched and
the gameplay remains solid throughout of
course you can pay to cut down your Greg
time but ultimately this is not pay to
win this may change in future as the
game receives regular updates as I said
but not at present this is not pay to
win I've got to admit from the outset I
had no intention of playing this game
and if it cost money not I would not
have bought it because I was firmly in
the belief that paladin's is a ripoff of
overwatch but I'm bloody glad I tried it
it's free so you should try it too I
can't think of a reason not to it's even
better with friends and you are rewarded
for playing with your mate and the game
becomes far more entertaining when you
can shout abuse at your best mate or
playing his class wrong if that's not
enough to make you try paladins then I
have one last thing to send you over the
edge horses
yeah mounts are here to get you back
into the fight faster I know it's not a
great reason birthdays my list horses
are cool I may even try to unlock the
unicorn I never thought I'd say
something like that so I've gone from
being in resolute opposition to paladin
to an ambassador for people to try it
what do you think have you played belong
within five minutes before judging this
one keeping mind it's still a beta so
yeah there's a few bugs I've neglected
to mention without a doubt paladins is
heavily influenced by overwatch but the
depth it offers if you stick around long
enough to see it is damn impressive
please let me know your thoughts and
maybe let's start a debate below
I'm Adam from Playstation grenades I'll
see you next time
you
[Music]